foreign
is in Norfolk Virginia hi Maria welcome
to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave thank you for taking my call my
husband thanks you as well you uh you
have changed our lives and ways that we
can't even imagine
um and I'm calling because we're stuck
in a situation and I kind of already
know the answer but we're not sure how
to go about it we have a relative that
has been sending us silver coins and we
don't think they're worth very much but
she claims that they're going to be
worth a whole lot of money in the future
we would like to not have them anymore I
guess or maybe we just want to invest in
other ways and she's not understanding
that how would you go about
approaching her on this scenario because
she's taking a very strong stance on
hmm who is this his mother his mother
yes it is my mother-in-law
yeah that was fairly easy yes so talk me
out of this because
um I've
taken calls on my show about
mother-in-laws who just keep showing up
mother-in-laws who criticize parenting
mother-in-laws who
all all sorts of things that are very
disruptive
sounds like your mother-in-law just
mails a bag of coins
well it actually isn't
um she's not very good financially to
begin with um that was easy to get and
we have quite a bit of problems with
that and my husband and I are the exact
opposite we almost have our business
entirely paid for our homes page so how
much how much is the value of the coin
she's sending you a year
well when I found a coin place that was
local today there may be a 24 worth
they're just silver
so what does it matter
right and that's what we keep saying no
I mean throw them in a bucket in the
bottom of the garage and forget it
okay if you throw 24 out the window of
your car on the way to church and that
makes your mother-in-law happy oh that's
24 bucks well spent that's good it's a
great purchase wait is it is it bigger
are you worried about how she's slowly
um
ruining herself financially and she's
going to be moving in with you guys is
that what this what's this ultimately
about no
um well the thing is is we would be the
only ones that would be financially able
to even care for her and would have a
home that would suit her needs come that
you know time frame do you think she's
paying two thousand dollars for twenty
four dollars worth of coins
I do honestly and so does my husband we
wouldn't be surprised she's very naive
um in that aspect uh you know she just
lives off Social Security as far as we
know yeah I I think your husband not you
you don't need to even be in the
conversation you'll be the wicked
stepdaughter
in this oh I already am yeah we can add
layers to that with this conversation so
I think he just says yeah Mom I'm
worried about you how much do you pay
for these coins because I checked it out
and they're worth 24 dollars
right and just see what she says and
just to add a lack the love to her as
far as you all are concerned
I would throw them in a bag in the
bottom seriously in a bucket in the
garage and not worry about it I wouldn't
upset somebody I wouldn't I wouldn't
upset somebody for 24. and I think the
the the I think the coins are a proxy
for a bigger conversation which is are
we going to let her come live here and
if so what's that going to cost us
what's what what things kind of like are
we going to send our kid to college in
five years what do we have to start
doing right now to either lay the
groundwork you're not coming here or to
make it a reality and it's easy to focus
on the coins but it sounds like there's
a much bigger picture at play yeah she's
she's using this as leverage it's a
future it's the uh this is a symbol
camel's nose Under the Tent of a bigger
frustration yes you're getting ready to
get it's getting ready to get a big deal
here soon yeah so yeah it's not twenty
four dollars she's paying 25 and you're
getting 24 worth I wouldn't worry about
it but if she's paying two thousand
dollars then that's just your husband
stopping her from getting ripped off
that's right